well joining me now is the security and
defense analyst professor michael clark
who's here with me now um it's great to
have you here michael just what are the
plans then that russia is proposing at
the moment what are they planning next
well what the russians are doing at the
moment is transferring forces from the
north towards the southwest they talks
very it's very donetsk and vicinsk about
a month ago now and they're pushing
towards the next big places slaviansk
and south island against kramatos those
are the big battles to come but they've
made no progress they're very close to
slavians haven't moved they haven't even
as far as we can tell taken back mutt
which is one place on the way to
slaviansk and they don't seem to have
taken seversk another small place
they're offensive in the north has
stopped and the reason we're pretty sure
about that is because they seem to be
moving troops and equipment to the to
the southwest towards this other area
around kirshen where where they are
under pressure and so what we're seeing
at the moment is the russians are as it
were in a sense taking a pause because
they're having to hang on for this big
offensive which the ukrainians are
mounting and have been working on now
for a couple of months down in the
southwest
so the question is why is cursing then
more important for russia it's much more
important because kershaw's the first
big city that the russians took it would
be a massive humiliation if they were to
lose it and what the ukrainians are
trying to do is to conduct a wide area
offensive not village by village but to
take as it were the whole area and trap
the uh 42nd combined arms army inside
kirschen and what the russians of the
ukrainians have done they've been able
to get the antonisky bridge which is the
main m14 bridge that runs through
cursion and the now reports that they've
taken the p-47 bridge out
which is the p-47 highway which is
another main bridge to the further
upstream to to the north east of kershan
and if they've taken those bridges out
it's effectively made them unusable they
haven't they haven't destroyed the
bridges but they've put enough holes in
them to make them unusable the russians
are having to use pontoon bridges to get
stuff across to the west recursion what
the um
what the ukrainians are trying to do is
to isolate this combined arms army
inside cursion and then move against
them and towards the western outskirts
of cursion the the forward edge of the
battle area as they call it the fever is
only about 10 kilometers away so big
things are happening there they're not
so obvious in um
arrows on a map but i think we'll see
some big movements there in the next
couple of weeks
very very interesting to get your
analysis there professor michael clark
as always thank you very much indeed